serious question spoiler hey Santos do
you really need to wear armor all the
time
you control space-time and reality why
not try something a little more
comfortable kickback Snoke has a pretty
dope ass robe you should hit above here
have those grapes
DeSales ever get food stuck in his chin
grooves and aren't his fingers too big
to clean them out gingivitis so did you
see that Tobias from Arrested
Development's and the fake reality
Thanos creates at the collectors place
is Thanos like secretly a big comedy
nerd does he sit down after a genocide
and just re-watch mr. show could he snap
his fingers and bring back community
shows gonna last three weeks how was
Peter Parker going to explain to his
schoolmates how he disappeared somewhere
over the Queensboro Bridge something
something penis Parker is the snap to
kill half of everyone in the universe
built into the Infinity Gauntlet is it
like a hot key or an add-on basically
what I'm asking is is the Infinity
Gauntlet the power I love to power glove
it's so bad his Hawkeye okay
vanos is all about balance but is
cutting something in half the same as
balancing it way more than half of
everyone is gonna die because of that
what if the universe has an odd number
of people what poor schmuck gets haft
let's have top if it's dangling whoa
does this mean half the defenders are
dead or even better all the defenders
are dead but who will protect our always
is that kid from Iron Man three okay is
Aunt May okay no I'll RB what happens
when the universe over populates again
just keep snapping
why not snap to lower the birthrate it's
not to make the universe bigger or snap
to stop being such an old raisin face
dick this has been snapchat could the
reality stone bring back Terrence Howard
and Edward Norton man I hope not they
have some thoughts on the script I have
to stay home and guard the sanctum
that's a pretty good way of getting out
of something you don't want to deal with
no questions here just well played one
who's Andy are we sure the Infinity
stones reflect all the elements of the
universe or as that gauntlet missing a
funk stone funk stone is canon if Peter
Parker is a teenager who doesn't know a
lot about Star Wars or the aliens
franchise does that mean they're not
pumping out crappy sequels for those
movies in the MCU like why isn't he
quoting the prequels are talking about
alien covenant from my point of view the
Avengers are evil is Valkyrie okay
it's Korg okay what was your question
again birth is it weirder than Paul
Bettany's in his 40s and Elizabeth
Olsen's in her 20s or that scarlet
witch's in her 20s envisions a robot aw
so is he still technically their Butler
look I know Thor is a God and all but
does that mean he can't get a bacterial
infection because that I was definitely
in a raccoons butthole you'd think he'd
ask guard I know they tried to say it's
just a fake in Ragnarok but the Infinity
Gauntlet in that first Thor movie makes
no sense right like hepatitis even made
the real one yet
and if you're gonna make a forgery why
put all the Infinity stones in it when I
lied on my report card I gave myself C's
not AIDS it's more believable that way
I hope [ __ ] he fired someone for this if
big dinklage is out there in space with
a magic Forge capable of making Thanos
killing weapons why wasn't he cranking
those out full time make ten and give
one to every avenger man you get him on
here and you get him here and you get
him you'll hear what work at Black Widow
and Falcon up two for two years just
laying low do they have a cap cave is
Falcon caps robbing it offensive to call
Falcon robbing I know a lot about bird
law bird laws now governed by reason is
the Galaga guy okay
what about struggling Asgardian actor
Matt Damon is Matt Damon dead wait does
that leave us with us guardian actor Ben
Affleck ooh interesting crossover was a
Red Skull cosplaying as the Grim Reaper
he was wearing a Hydra uniform when he
left did he look at his reflection see a
tad her black cloak and just decided to
kind of own it the spookiest not see
what's tree puberty like I bet it still
has to do with the changes to your nuts